thank you fans so much for um for voting
i don't get to see you i'm glad to see
you guys hardly at all this year um but
stuff like this just
it means so much to me and just lets me
know that you're just still doing what
you do which is just
given the love carrie picked up video of
the year and female video of the year
for drinking alone
basically the theme song for 2020.
the two awards last night meant history
was made she's won 22 cmt awards over
her career the most by
any artist i have kind of this hallway
in in my house that is kind of
designated for these things and it's all
lit up pretty
and um you know if it's whenever i pass
by
it's just kind of like oh like look at
look at those so
i'm definitely on display because i'm
really proud of them and while carrie
has been a staple in the country scene
since 2006 when she won breakthrough
video of the year for jesus take the
wheel
taylor swift took some time away to
conquer pop music
but t swift hasn't forgotten her roots
and last night
13 years after her win for breakthrough
video of the year for tim mcgraw
she presented the award and cmt
breakthrough video of the year
is i hope by gabby barrett
congratulations yes the night was filled
with amazing moments
from co-host kane brown performing
worship you to halsey and kelsey
ballerini
giving us coyote ugly vibes while
performing the other girl
to the one and only shania twain hitting
us with a classic from switzerland
[Music]
and for blake shelton he's definitely
stolen girlfriend gwen stefani's heart
the two picked up best collaborative
video for nobody but you
which shocked them because they were up
against dan and shea's collab with
justin bieber
i told gwen that when i saw who the
other nominees were in our category
literally
it was like well that would have been
cool but i don't know what our chances
of beating
justin bieber are but the most powerful
moment of the night had to be when
jennifer nettles was honored with the
first ever
cmt equal play award recognizing the
sugarland singer's work to get women and
diverse artists heard on country radio
just as much as their white male
counterparts thank you to all the fans
and especially
my artists my sisters out there who
continue to burn the holy fire i am so
proud
to be a part of this legacy of women in
country music with you and i am so proud
of the stories that we tell
we have more to do as soon as we can and
i can't wait to do it all
alongside you holding your hands thank
you